just under 50 days from the first real
test of 2024 the Iowa caucus now Trump
is leading nationally we all know by a
lot and he's also leading in Iowa he's
at 47% in the Hawkeye State according to
the RCP average his closest competitor
is Ronda santis of course the governor
of Florida he's at 177% Nikki Haley
trailing in third with 14 it's not
really surprising that Haley because of
where the things stand has turned her
sights on DeSantis according to one top
campaign Finance expert her Super PAC
has spent $3.6 million against the
Florida governor that's $25,000 only
against Biden and against Trump she
spent zero now as I've said for months
there's Trump and then there's everyone
else but there's the battle for number
two and that's between DeSantis and
Haley that's why I offered to host a
debate between the two on the angle only
one Governor Dan santis has responded
and he accepted he joins me now Governor
good to see you tonight um why do you
think Nikki Haley has not responded
yet well she probably wouldn't like uh
what the debate would be about I mean I
think she has taken very very
establishment oriented positions uh we
know she had the social media proposal
to force everybody uh to give their
names which we know would be weaponized
against conservatives anybody that's
been alive for the last three or four
years knows how that censorship regime
Works uh she's also said no limits on
immigration that CEOs should determine
our immigration policy no I think
immigration policy should be what's in
the best interest of the American people
uh and American workers uh she also took
the side of Disney against the State of
Florida and against us protecting our
kids we had a debate about making sure
that our young kids in elementary school
were not subjected uh to sexualized
curriculum and transgender ideology uh
we were right to stand with the kids of
course she cited with the corporation so
I think she's just fundamentally out of
step with Republican voters uh I think
she's relying on liberal media to prop
her up uh but I'm game for the debate uh
you know I'll debate any of these folks
I think that's what it's all about yeah
I think it would be interesting and very
informative for uh the viewers and for
people out there just kind of want to
know more about you know who's number
two and number three and who should
really be in second place at this point
um by the way on that issue of
immigration uh there was a new report
out Governor by the group Doctors
Without Borders and it said at least 400
female and child migrants making the
journey to the US border have been
brutalized in so-called rape tents in
October alone 107 rape survivors
including 59 people in a single week
they were treated the youngest victims
were 11 12 and 16 we know the Biden
Administration they don't care they
don't care about the collateral damage
and open border policy but how would
president DeSantis confront this issue
would you Deport people who are here now
and to deter people from coming and thus
save uh the fate of these uh young women
who are being
brutalized of course if there's not a
sanction for coming illegally you're
never going to stop the problem so we'll
declared to be a National Emergency on
day one we'll send troops to the Border
we'll stop the Asylum fraud we'll do
remain in Mexico I'm going to charge
fees on foreign remittance remittances
to be able to fund construction of the
border wall uh but yes when people come
illegally we are sending them back and
we've got 8 million that have come under
Biden we need to send them all back we
don't know who they are uh they've come
from all around the world uh if they
come from Iran they've come from Russia
China the Middle East uh there will
absolutely be perspective terrorists
that have come across I think there will
be a terrorist attack that we be able to
link to our border he's put our people
in Jeopardy but we also have to
understand why do you have sex
trafficking why do you have human
trafficking at this level it's because
the Mexican drug cartels are running the
show so we're going to categorize them
as a foreign terrorist organization
authorize the use of deadly military
force because they are invading our
country they are committing all these
serious crimes but they're killing tens
of thousands of our citizens by bringing
fentol that's going to every community
in the country it's not just border
communities and I've met so many Angel
moms over the course of the last year
year and a half who've lost a child
usually a high school or college Age kid
uh to drug drug basically being poison
they may take a pill that's laced with
fentol and then that's it and they die
we've got to stop this Governor uh Bob
Vander plats uh I know him he's the in
influential Iowa Faith leader I he
recently gave you his endorsement which
is Coveted in in the state but now
they're questions surrounding the money
he received from groups linked to your
campaign now he was asked about this
last week on Special Report
watch The santis Campaign a Super PAC
linked to him a nonprofit group
supporting him together paid 995,000 in
recent months to the family leader
Foundation uh according to campaign
Finance reports is that not true or
that's true well it's definitely true
and I'd encourage everybody to read the
reuter's article everything we do is
above
board uh governor the allegations
obviously or the inference here would be
that it was like a pay to play to get an
endorsement um you have a chance to
clear that
up well uh this pack I don't control as
you know but they paid for advertising
so that's a very influential group of
evangelicals in Iowa they've hosted a
number of major events they had a summer
event we just had the Thanksgiving Forum
so they're paying to be able to be in
programs and to be able to advertise uh
the candidacy and that happens that's
frequently happened but Bob Vander
platz's endorsement is not for sale uh
he's got a great reputation he's become
a friend of of Casey and me along the
way he's very influential in Iowa and so
it's a scarless charge is without Merit
and you know if somebody endorses
somebody other than you you don't always
have to lash out and attack the person
who made the endorsement it's a primary
people can have uh different choices in
this and there's not always an ulterior
motive so uh I think the attacks against
Bob Vander plats have been have been out
of bounds just as I think the attacks
against Governor Kim Reynolds have been
out of bounds um and Governor you're
rcking up um a lot of faith endorsements
Nikki Haley and I've tweeted a lot of
this out or exit out we say exit out now
but we I I've the donors big donors are
turning out for Haley now I actually
think that's not a bad thing for you I
actually think that's kind of a that
says a lot to me about why they think
she you know should get the money or she
should get the nod from them what does
that tell you and does it concern you
regarding your own
finances no we're doing very well uh
We've uh consistently outpaced uh her
and fundraising will continue to do that
but uh I think that what it shows is I
have consistently proven that I will do
what I think is right regardless of what
donors say we've taken on Disney we've
taken on big Pharma we took on the sugar
industry in Florida when we did our
Everglades plan so I've been able to do
that and my view is let the chips fall
where they may do what you think is
right don't twist yourself in a pretzel
to try to cow out of people just for
donations and oh by the way uh a lot of
the folks on Wall Street have policy
positions that are just anathema to the
American people you will not win an
election in this country Nationwide if
you're adopting their platform I think
we've seen that with Republicans who've
tried to do that in the past so I'm
doing what I think is right I think
we'll end up being much better off for
that uh throughout this process Governor
finally a question I asked my previous
panel disturbing numbers coming out of
fundraising from the RNC as compared to
their Democrat counterpart organization
uh are you concerned under the
leadership of R McDaniel that the party
is not raising what they need to raise
to help in some of these other uh races
across the country and obviously
nationally as
well well we'll be able to fix that as a
nominee just like I did in Florida we
created a juggernaut in the State of
Florida when I became Governor we had
300,000 more registered Democrats than
Republicans and we never had more RS
than D's in Florida history now after
five years we have
670,000 more registered Republicans we
took a swing state we turned it into a
red state with a 20-point victory when
you produce leadership and success uh
all those fundraising issues solve
themselves well that's a question you
need somebody who's leading the charge
you need somebody who's leading the
charge like I did in Florida who's going
to inspire people to want to support the
effort because they see uh that your
vision is going in the right direction
in Florida we'll be able to do it there
should be no change at the RNC no CH
it'sing out I actually I I I called for
change after the midterms I was the only
presidential candidate running that
called for change I wasn't running at
the time but my view was we've lost all
these elections in a row why are we
continue to do but here's the thing as
the nominee I will be responsible for
doing it and I will get the job done
regardless of who the chairman of it is
I led the drive in Florida I'll lead the
drive nationally we can do it we just
need leadership yeah we need a
Republican party that has a message
Beyond just you know B Biden bad uh
Governor great to see you thank you so
much hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else